aujourd'hui j'ai une interview philippe
poutou le candidat du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste un parti classé à
l'extrême gauche c'est sa troisième
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
il a obtenu
1.481.091 % des voix en 2007 pour les
prochains jours les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle vont donc
participer à cette interview face cachée
chaque candidat fait face à un écran
géant sur lequel défilent des émaux j en
appuyant successivement sur le buzzer et
l'arrêtent la roue sur un et mogi dont
la face cachée peut révéler une archive
un jeu une citation une carte ou encore
des surprises et c'est donc à chaque
fois le point de départ vers des
questions au passage vous l'imaginez
chaque interview de ce type demande
énormément de préparation de notre côté
on a fait le choix d'interviewer tous
les candidats qui obtienne les 500
parrainages d'élus qui leur permettent
d'être officiellement candidat le truc
c'est que en raison du nombre de
candidats potentiels et de l'élection
qui approche rapidement eh bien on est
obligé de commencer à tourner certaines
des interviews avant la clôture de cette
récolte des parrainages au moment où on
diffuse cette vidéo donc philippe poutou
n'est pas assuré d'obtenir ces 500
parrainages d'élus pour être candidat ça
me semble donc important de le
mentionner et d'être plus largement
transparence sur la façon d'avancer sur
ce format au vu notamment du timing et
du temps de préparation que nécessitent
chaque interview bref abonnez vous pour
ne pas louper ces entretiens qui arrive
chaque jeudi et dimanche à 19 heures et
sans plus tarder je vous laisse avec
l'interview bonjour philippoteaux java
merci beaucoup déjà d'avoir accepté mon
invitation
on va commencer avec cette roue qui se
lance pour cette première question je
voulais s'appuyer qu'on voulait sur le
buzzer
et s'arrête sur un premier et mogi c'est
donc un journal jusqu'ici tout va bien
derrière cette màj il ya un titre
d'article qui a été publié récemment je
vais vous montrer le titre de l'article
je vous laisse le lire à voix haute et
ensuite me faire part de ce que vous
ressentez à sa lecture alors c'est
l'express l'ancien candidat à la
présidentielle philippe poutou annonce
avoir été licencié voilà donc sutil
c'est l'ancien candidat du npa à
l'élection présentielle de 17 a reçu
vendredi sans autorisation
administrative de licenciement donc ça
ça doit dater de
18 il ya deux ans trois ans n'ont plus
que ça ça passe vite ouais mais c'est le
licenciement de lusine ford voilà il ya
une bataille de 12 13 ans à peu près
contre la fermeture de l'usiné on a
réussi à abandonner a fait reculer ford
et pierre qui bout du compte on a fini
par perdre face à la multinationale ford
qui a liquidé toutes les idées un
millier d'emplois à peu près là il ya
l'autre usine à côté qui va être aussi
certainement liquidés et puis voilà et
puis à côté saab et les pouvoirs publics
à ce moment là en laisser faire un même
s'il y avait des grands coups de gueule
de du ministre le maire à l'époque ou
même de macron et qui est intervenu dans
le dossier mais finalement ils ont ils
ont capitulé ils ont laissé ford mais
comme il est aujourd'hui plein des
usines fermées voilà donc c'est
l'histoire mon histoire d'à c'est
l'histoire de deux milliers de salariés
de dizaines de milliers de salariés et
c'est toujours d'actualité aujourd'hui
on voit les licenciements et les
fermetures et les liquidations qui se
multiplient y compris pendant la crise
sanitaire ça effectivement bruno le
maire avait réagi notamment en
fustigeant l'attitude indigne de fort en
disant que en rejetant toutes les offres
de reprise de l'usiné dans laquelle vous
travaillez en fait ça ça ne s'est pas
beaucoup d'options qu'est ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire en tant que si vous
êtes président dans ce genre de
situation parce que vous parlez
notamment d'interdire les licenciements
comment est-ce que ça se passerait si
pendant cette situation qui a été la
vôtre et se pourrait que c'est important
c'est d'en parler voilà c'est pas si je
suis président c'est on imagine nous que
c'est une question de rapport de forces
c'est pas juste un une élection ou un
changement de président c'est vraiment à
la question de la remise en cause
l'organisation capitaliste des choses
donc là il ya un pouvoir patronal qui
est lié à sa propriété ford possède une
usine produit ce qu'il veut et comme il
veut et quand il y est c'est lui qui
gère financièrement un pic anti di bella
serré c'est papa c'est pas facile ou un
peu plus belles fermes et ça c'est là
c'est légal c'est le sais parce que liée
à la propriété et donc le pouvoir
patronal il dépend de cette propriété
dont nous la réponse qu'on a c'est
évidemment de résister le plus possible
pour empêcher des plans de licenciements
mais on voit qu'on n'est pas assez fort
pour ça et que de toute façon ce qui
l'emportent c'est la volonté patronale
donc la seule la seule la seule façon
d'empêcher ce pouvoir de nuisance la
seule façon de contenir tous abaissé de
reprendre la propriété et donc nous on
parle de réquisition pour ford ont
défendu l'idée de la réquisition l'état
pour personnes ont du sens public qui
réquisitionne alors malheureusement
l'état et la puissance publique sont
plutôt complices des patrons donc c'est
un peu difficile mais c'est là où ça
pose de problème de bataille de salariés
mais pas tous seuls dans leur coin en
lien avec la population c'est pour ça
qu'on parle de convergence des luttes
public-privé enfin en fait l'emploi
d'une personne quelque part c'est
l'emploi de tout le monde donc c'est
essaie aussi de faire mais ça passe
forcément par la réquisition ou
l'expropriation c'est les idées que
demont défense et à les reprendre
l'outil de travail et donc le
collectiviser et le m soit soit c'est
l'état qui reprend mais aussi ce qui
compte ce serait que les salariés en
autogestion et puissent contrôler leur
propre outil de travail et d idée même
de logiciels de décider même comment ils
produisent de quelle manière ils
organisent la production et donc ça
serait important mais là ça relève d'un
problème politique de fond de démocratie
au sein de la société en général quand
on va passer à limoges y suivant ça ça
vous va sarr défilé je reste ap quand
vous roulez avec de suite on perd pas de
temps c'est ça on perd pas de temps
c'est un match normal c'est maintenant
que ça s'arrête donc là en l'occurrence
les mots j c'est un beau jake une bulle
de conversation le principe c'est quoi
il ya un texte qui va s'afficher c'est
en fait une déclaration qui a été faite
par un candidat je vous pose à bord de
l'a lire à voix haute et ensuite de
deviner qui a prononcé ces mots que vous
allez vous allez voir est ce que oui ou
non vous serez candidat en 2022 non je
resterai à la retraite c'est moi qui
l'ait dit
le nom d chez les alliés de chez vous
allez le voir c'était bon effectivement
en 2017 chez france info qu'est ce qui
s'est passé qu'est-ce qui a fait que
vous avez du coup et c'est bien de
parler de ça parce que ben oui mais même
en 2017 quand j'étais candidat la
première fois j'avais dit que je ne
serai pas en 2022 en 2020 non 12 17
euros
hélas oui mais oui 2022 pareil mais
parce qu'en fait mais même
collectivement c'était pas prévu comme
ça parce qu'il n'y a aucune raison que
ce soit toujours le même où là même
qu'ils soient là et là entre autres
c'était toujours après olivier
besancenot à deux reprises mois de
reprise c'était évident pour tout le
monde qu'on change et puis surtout quand
on pense à ce que soit une camarade qui
nous représente et donc c'était prévu
comme ça alors moi je le faisais sous
forme d'humour parce que j'ai 55 ans et
nous on est pour la retraite à 55 ans
pour les travaux pénibles et donc comme
j'avais fait les trois huit pendant très
longtemps il dit moi je serai à la
retraite donc ça sera plus loin et là
ben ouais on n'a pas réussi ce qu'on
voulait faire parce que parce qu'on
maîtrise pas tout et
la l'élection présentielle c'est
compliqué parce qu'il nous faut des
parrainages et des parrainages il en
faut 500 les parrainages d'élus donc et
on n'a pas d'élu donc il faut aller les
chercher et c'est très compliqué donc le
calcul qu'on a fait en plus on était en
pleine crise sanitaire quand on a décidé
de la candidature donc en juin dernier
et toutes ces difficultés là puis en
plus on a un parti avec des forces
plutôt limité et on s'est dit ah ben
ouais un visage déjà connu déjà dans le
paysage politique ça ne pouvait que nous
aider pour à obtenir les parrainages
alors qu'on savait que ce serait quand
même assez que sachant qu'il ya eu aussi
là dessus des tensions au sein même de
votre parti donc je rappellerai nouveau
parti anticapitaliste avec un candidat
anastasie bossi qui a qui s'est porté
candidat finalement de son côté aussi
donc ça montre aussi ne jamais évident
est la particularité du npa c'est que ça
fait dix ans qu'on a des tensions donc
en fait y'a pas de nouveauté là dessus
on a toujours des camarades qui ont
refusé de faire la campagne qui sont
partis fin voilà on a une vie un peu un
peu mou vement moment une vie interne
mais bon il n'ya pas que le npa beaucoup
d'organisation à diochon sinaloa c'est
aussi un peu un signe des temps quoi la
crise elle fait mal à tout le monde et
on espère qu'au bout du compte ça sera
le bon calcul mais en 2027 je serais
vraiment à la retraite ça veut garder
l'image et si je suis candidat en 2007
mais là c'est que vous remonterez en 4
verra on verra ça on va remettre du coup
le la roue avec les logiques défilé je
vous laisse aller le stopper et elle
fait très bien on perd pas de temps
c'est des livres comme vous voyez
jusqu'ici tout va bien concrètement des
recettes et mogi il ya une définition
qui va s'afficher et donc je vous
propose de lire cette définition que
vous puissiez la lyre et ensuite on va
pouvoir en parler la définition du coup
c'est la suivante jouer cela lire
capitalisme systèmes économiques et de
société dont les fondements sont
l'entreprise privée la liberté du marché
et la recherche du profit donc ça c'est
d'après le larousse une combinaison de
plusieurs éléments qui viennent je du
larousse c'est intéressant pour moi d'en
parler parce que vous êtes donc le
candidat du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste c'est quoi pour vous
votre vision du capitalisme bah ouais
mais là la définition elle est pas mal
quoi c'est enfin nous un anti
capitaliste à dire quand on pense que en
fait au départ tous les problèmes
aujourd'hui d'inégalités sociales de
précarité fais tout toute notre
difficulté la souffrance et licenciement
fin tous les sujets puis même la crise
environnementale
la question des migrants fin tout nous
on pense que tout ça c'est lié un
système politique et économique c'est le
capitalisme parce qu'en fait on est une
société qui est dirigé par départ mais
ceux qui possèdent donc ceux qui
dirigent l'économie leur seul problème
mais c'est le profit c'est la
rentabilité à court terme et en aucune
manière il s'agit d'une économique est
tourné vers les intérêts de la
population ou tout simplement les
questions environnementales
donc nous on pense que cette ce système
là il est complètement pourri deux fnb
d'ailleurs les décennies passant ça la
crise s'approfondit et les réponses du
capitalisme à la crise ne font
qu'aggraver la crise vous aviez le
slogan de nos vies pas le retrouvait
pourtant web et du coup nous on pense
que c'est vraiment une question de
système qu'il faut qu'on discute et donc
oui on est sur le renversement de ce
système là et même c'est ce qui est plus
réaliste c'est de discuter de ça parce
que sinon on va en va à la catastrophe
pour aller vers eux pour aller vers quoi
du coup parce que très concrètement le
donc avant le npa il y avait la ligue
communiste révolutionnaire est ce que
vous considérez vous comme communiste
aujourd'hui et si oui pour que jean
visualise concrètement quels et du coup
le web est tout à fait on reste dans la
tradition
du mouvement envoyé depuis le milieu du
19e siècle avec la gueule ce marx rosa
luxembourg
louise michel la commune de paris les
ninjas voilà je vous fais là elle un peu
ce petit historique du combat communiste
quoi pour une société communiste mais
d'un dents dans cette idée justement
d'une économie où il n'y a pas la
propriété privée des moyens de
production dans tout ce qui produit les
richesses dans la société se doit être
collectiviser est donc une économie qui
a uni à un contrôle public de tout ça
donc ça suppose évidemment une
population politisé enfin qui sans
qu'ils se mêlent de ces affaires là et
on discute d'une économie réelle cherche
à voir ce qu'on produit comment le
produit est en fonction mais il ya des
problèmes sociaux ou des problèmes
environnementaux et donc on est dans
cette idée là alors après on s'appelle
nouveau parti anticapitaliste pascal
après aurillac
vous voulez qu'on soit un parti un peu
plus large qu'elle sert on n'a pas
vraiment réussi parce qu'on voulait
englober les courants libertaires enfin
comment tu es comme essayer de faire
aussi jean luc mélenchon peut-être sur
un léger rebond politiquement un peu
différent mais un peu moins radical et
pommeau l'anticapitalisme et c'est vrai
que voilà c'est façon il ya forcément il
ya des problèmes on essaie de trouver
des pensant voit bien quelle faiblesse
politique du côté des opprimés et on
essaie de voir comment on peut
reconstruire des outils qui nous
permettent de se défendre et donc c'est
la question de comment on construit en
partie avec un regroupement qui où c'est
con mais la délimitation donc l'histoire
nouveau parti anticapitaliste c'est ça
mais voilà l'objectif c'est le
renversement de cette société là mais à
l'échelle planétaire fait intéressant
d'avoir cette définition pour comprendre
votre vision sur l'état de la société
aujourd'hui on va passer du coup à la
prochaine question je relance la roue et
je vais vous laisser du coût de la
stopper
on est sur un chronomètre l'idée du
chronomètre c'est quoi c'est que je vous
poser une série de questions et en une
minute vous allez devoir répondre à un
maximum de ces questions le principe
tous les candidats vont le faire c'est
concrètement de mieux comprendre votre
programme de connaître certains aspects
c'est un détail de votre votre programme
de votre vision est là aussi de la
société et donc vous allez avoir 60
secondes pour répondre par oui ou par
non à chacune de ces questions d'après
mes 60 ans tout en tout pour tout les 4
mais là tout est question pour un
maximum de questions et après on pourra
éventuellement à voir en détail certains
certains éléments fait sportif ses
sorties mais l'idée étant au-delà des
autres questions on prend le temps sur
celle ci de pouvoir avoir aussi voir
d'autres d'autres sujets qu'on n'aurait
pas le temps d'aborder autrement
première question faut-il légaliser le
cannabis on dit oui si vous êtes
président de république est-ce que vous
habite aurier à l'elysée
l'enfant va faut-il supprimer le défilé
du 14 juillet oui faut-il interdire le
nutella
oui tel qu'il est est ce utile d'aller
sur mars
je peux pas dire que nathalie arthaud
pourrait-elle être votre première
ministre a compliqué pour plein de
raisons est ce que vous êtes favorable à
l'uniforme à l'école mort a priori non
faut-il maintenir le pass vaccinale non
faut-il quitté l'union européenne ce
compliqué oui ben là comme ça c'est
compliqué ça serait plutôt pour enfin
sortir de cette union il travaille et de
l'europe et du trailer faut-il autoriser
l'euthanasie en france tu penses quoi le
président de la république at il trop de
pouvoir aujourd'hui mais sur
achetez-vous sur amazon non peut-on
aimer son travail
oui c'est très très difficile
aujourd'hui de plus en plus difficile
mais il y en a certainement qui doit un
peu apprécié ce qu'ils font la russie
est elle un allié de la france
je pense que les aliens y n'ont a priori
non on va passer à la question suivante
pour sa du court mais la roue et je vous
laisse la stopper
alors scellé maugis vidéo derrière
c'était maugis vous l'aurez compris il
ya une vidéo on va donc la regarder
ensemble et en parler juste après cette
vidéo je vous préviens devrait pas trop
vous surprendre je pense que vous la
connaissez mais elle va être justement
intéressante à analyser ensemble juste
après on la regarde tout de suite fillon
voilà il est en face de moi que des
histoires et plus on fouille plus plus
on sent la corruption puis on sent la
triche et à côté de ça donc en plus et
des bonhommes qui qui nous explique
qu'il faut la rigueur qu'il faut
l'austérité et eux mêmes ils piquent
dans les caisses publiques donc il ya
comme ça oui dans d'accord merci donc
bon c'est ce que j'ai dit je les dis
vous aviez marqué les esprits en 2017 et
beaucoup de gens vous ont peut-être
connu avec ses punchlines qui ont été
lâchés lors d'un débat de premier tour
en 2017 est ce que vous trouvez que les
médias vous réduisent trop aux candidats
justement capable de lâcher de
punchlines est parfois trop
d'abord on est quasiment à éviter ou
jamais invité il ya que dans les
campagnes présidentielles où là il ya
une obligation d'égalité de temps de
parole ou n'est qu'une obligation
d'équité c'est là où on apparaît un peu
plus donc déjà il ya ce problème là
ensuite c'est vrai qu'au mais il n'y a
pas connu c'est que la politique allait
elle se résume beaucoup à des phrases
campanac même quasiment que ce à quoi
des phrases ou des ce qu'ils appellent
des buzz et ça déforme un peu
effectivement les choses et puis ça
évite de vraiment discuté de vraiment
confronter des idées bien côté un peu
artificielle bon là du coup là on en a
profité il y avait il ya eu quelques
phrases telles que quelques choix dans
le casse un choix de porter ce ton là
lors d'un débat à bâle et à sang c'est
ce qu'on aime c'est ce que moi je parle
comme ça donc je vais pas après c'est
vrai que la particularité c'est que
c'est la seule fois d'ailleurs où on est
on a en face de nous juste à côté tous
les candidats et puis tout ce qu'on aime
pas en fait tout ce qu'on peut pas voir
en peinture et qui à qui on a détaché à
dire donc c'est ce que je dis abandonné
je crois dans le débat c'est qu'en fait
je vais essayer de porter la parole va
tout ce qu'on a envie de dire merde on a
envie d'aller exprimer notre colère et
on a ces gens là qui sont responsables
de la souffrance plein de gens qui sont
responsables que ce sont des choix
politiques qui condamne des gens la
misère ou à des tas de difficulté donc
on est là en face d'eux et puis en plus
ces gens là sont des gens corrompus donc
si on peut le dire on va tant mieux mais
l'émission n'était pas fait pour ça on
avait une réunion nous ensemble les
camarades du npa préparer l'émission way
est en fait on essayait de justement
c'était tout saucissonné et puis on
essayait à chaque thème de placer un peu
d éléments de notre programme et on nous
avait conseillé de ne pas attaquer les
autres candidats et la belle à ces
sorties parce que c'était impossible à
aman de ne pas dire ce qu'on avait envie
de dire voilà mais c'est vrai que ça
fait du buzz mais en fait il ya le buzz
au niveau de la phrase où la formule
mais en fait ça a provoqué beaucoup de
fierté chez plein de gens et parce qu'en
fait et c'est ça que nous aussi on
essaie de faire de racan pas de regrets
sur ce jour là n'ont pas du tout fait
avec façon après enfin n'y a aucun même
le t-shirt quel effet beaucoup fantasmer
tous les réacs c'est ça fait partie de
ce qu'on est de toute façon ou de ce que
je suis de ce qu'on est en collectivité
mais ce qui est important c'est que et
c'est ça qu'on voudrait refaire dans
cette campagne là on subit tellement
l'idéologie dominante ont subi tellement
que des trucs ultralibéraux même raciste
fasciste enfin l'ambiance de la campagne
aujourd'hui elle et elle est terrible
pour ça et donc on étouffe quand on
étouffe et puis on sait qu'on est des
millions à avoir envie d'entendre autre
chose ou de dire autre chose et le fait
que nous le disent on n'est pas des
super héros mais le fait de le dire eh
ben ça peut faire du bien et même tout
ce qu'on espère c'est que ça puisse
redonner de la confiance redonner de la
légitimité à des combats et derrière abb
a aidé à ce qu'on reconstruise
mobilisation sociale et vous aviez dit à
l'époque il me semble c'est que c'était
chez jean jacques bourdin que vous aviez
parfois peur de dire des conneries dans
ce genre de débat ça pose aussi une
question plus large de se sentir
légitime dans un genre de débat est ce
que vous sentez légitime que vous êtes
présents ici et
bonjour d'ici pas ici là mais ici dans
ce débat de premier tour et est ce que
cette légitimité elle vient du coût d'un
sentiment de sentir représentatif de la
population comme ce que vous voyez ce
quelle est la légitimité non là on la
pense collectivement on pense que notre
parti aussi petit soit-il aussi fragile
soit il par rapport à ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure et les débats internes
compliqué il est archi légitime on est
des militants aux militants toute
l'année on ait investi dans les luttes
on a investi dans plein de choses et
elle se pose collectivement comme moi je
sois légitime pas plus que des tas de
camarades que l'ensemble des camarades
d'ailleurs donc voilà c'est moi il faut
en choisir un donc c'est mais on a cette
légitimité là et la légitimité donc
c'est celle d'un parti de militants de
militantes et c'est celle aussi de
l'idée anticapitaliste il faut qu'elle
soit représentée cette idée là il faut
qu'il ya des gens qui disent ce système
là c'est c'est pour il faut que ça
change il faut le renverser il faut se
battre avec les jeunes les moins jeunes
voilà c'est l'idée de la révolte donc ça
c'est ça qui est légitime et c'est ça
qui fait que moi j'ose faire ça sinon
sinon moi là dedans ben ouais mais dans
les plateaux télé d'ailleurs c'est hyper
dur un plateau télé parce que tout le
monde est hyper bien habillés et on a
l'impression que en fait on n'a rien à
faire ici tout est feutrée et tout est
pas ici je pas dans celui-là mais c'est
un peu comme un levier de la moquette
partout mais ça ressemble par exemple ça
les deux semaines et c'est vrai que
c'était en fait tout est fait pour qu'on
se sentent pas à l'aise on se sait pas
chez nous c'est pas notre milieu c'est
pas notre monde et donc c'est toujours
très difficile et la parole elle est
aussi difficile parce que en fait tout
le monde parle tranquillement ils
peuvent dire n'importe quoi ou rien du
tout ils pensent qu'ils sont légitimes a
parlé et nous au contraire ils nous font
peser les verts c'est à dire qu'il n'y
en a 62 ans se dit mais ce qu'on a
raison d'être là et c'est jamais simple
mais après on a une détermination et une
colère est donc cette légitimité
collective qui fait qu'on est là et
qu'on y tient et qu'on veut vraiment
bousculer les choses et on veut vraiment
les emmerder aussi mais c'est là où
c'est toujours quelque chose qui fait
débat y compris quand il eut c'est cette
prise de parole de l'autre côté il ya eu
des réactions gens qui disaient que ça
n'avait pas sa place dans ce genre est
un des bacs et c'est donc c'est double
d'où le fait de poser la question on
lance le prochaine la roue pour la
prochaine question
et je vous laisse la stopper
ce sera sur un graphique ça devenir
encore une chose les mots géographique
concrètement derrière vient graphique
jour oppose de le voir de le lire et de
dire un peu ce que vous en pensez
là en l'occurrence
vous le voyez c'est la question du prix
des carburants en france qu'est ce que
vous voyez est qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
là on le sait tous depuis quelques mois
en tout cas c'est bien la dernière
partie de la courbe parce que sa part de
2001 jusqu'à 2022 donc les deux
dernières années on voit que c'est une
courbe qui ne cesse de monter donc ça
c'est le carburant qui aujourd'hui enfin
le sans plomb il à 1,80 g pas coiffée
puis on se dit que ça va bientôt les
deux euros le litre mais mais c'est pas
que le carburant en fait hein c'est
c'est l'électricité le gaz
même l'alimentaire et puis c'est aussi
les loyers enfin voilà tout tout
augmente beaucoup et ça ça pose le
problème c'est quand les solutions face
à abel la solution il y en a plusieurs
et on discute de il ya des solutions
comme bloquer les prix là par exemple
carburant c'est total total qui est en
train d'annoncer qu'il va bientôt
annoncer 15 milliards de bénéfices à peu
près pour l'année 2000 21 un des plus
gros bénéfices bénéfices historiques on
voit que toutes ces multinationales de
l'énergie se font de l'argent en
pagaille alors donc déjà il ya cette
idée là de bloquer les prix mais au delà
de bloquer les prix c'est ce que j'ai
tout à l'heure qu'est ce que c'est la
peur qui sont les services publics de
l'énergie et donc un vrai service public
et donc c'est la question de
l'expropriation total 101 d'éviter
d'être en fait il faut que ce soit
rendue publique et justement cette
question du carburant de l'énergie il
faut que ce soit des outils qu'ils
soient sous contrôle des salariés de la
population et qu'on puisse discuter
justement à la fois des prix et puis de
comment produits de parce qu'elle
abandonne les énergies fossiles aussi
qu'il faut discuter parce que on est
justement c'est son mariage en mai la
vallasse et l'augmentation de
l'augmentation des prix en général et
c'est révélateur du système économique
dans lequel on vit c'est que baisse est
aussi une forme d'accumulation de
profits c'est aussi une forme de nous
faire payer à nous la crise à chaque
fois toujours un peu plus
il ya de quoi se révolter là il ya la
question du coup la du prix des
carburants car un problème connu par
beaucoup de français aujourd'hui qui ont
parfois besoin de la voiture pour se
déplacer au quotidien et c'est peut-être
moins le cas dans des grandes villes
mais c'est le cas dans d'autres d'autres
régions plus largement votre programme
sur l'écologie quels sont les 2 3 ans
mesure qui sont importantes pour vous
pour bien justement permettre cette
transition écologique dont on parle
depuis depuis début mai nous on reprend
une phrase qui est pas du tout de nous
c'est l'écho l'écologie sans lutte de
classe c du jardinage assez cette idée
d'une écologie radicale où on est on
défend l'idée d'une écologie radicale
d'une idée d'une écologie
anticapitaliste qui d'ailleurs est très
lié à tout un mouvement environnemental
jeunes de moins jeunes de 11 à 17 ans
vient de se passer d'énergie il ya deux
choses il ya là nous on pense qu'il faut
c'est ce que je disais à mon tout à
l'heure c'est qu'en fait sortir enfin
répondre à la crise climatique c'est
forcément se dégager des lois du profit
et des lois capitalistes c'est à dire en
fait c'est pour ça qu'on discute
vachement de socialisation dont quel
service public de l'énergie qui concerne
la socialisation d'une partie de
l'économie c'est la question des
transports aussi il faut que ce soit les
services publics les transports
collectifs on est pour la gratuité des
transports collectifs le manière à se
sortir de belles du besoin des voitures
de sortir du tout camion est de
développer le fait par exemple sur les
gratuits pour les transports collectifs
ouais mais après il ya toujours la
question des moyens derrière mais bon
les moyens et comment finances du pouce
et voilà bon c'est comme ça mais j'avais
pas fini sur la question les réponses
environnementale mais si on prend juste
un exemple précis qui serait la gratuité
des transports publics pour privilégier
donc mal eux l'utilisation des
transports publics qui sont plus
respectueux de l'environnement comment
est ce qu'on fait en sorte de rendre
cette salle gratuit combien ça coûte et
comment est ce qu'on le financerait ça
coûterait très cher mais combien
précisément non franchement je ne sais
pas mais par contre on sait combien
coûte à peu près le capitalisme en terme
de chômage de précarité de sous-emploi
de souffrance au travail et de mortalité
lié à la pauvreté donc ça on pourrait
envoyer plein de chiffres on pourrait
débattre là dessus c'est à dire le coût
du capitalisme le coût de cette économie
là il est énorme et nous on essaie de
répondre justement qu'une économie qui
fonctionnerait différemment elle
apporter des solutions autres et sur la
question des transports ok ça coûte cher
mais alors là on a quelques chiffres
c'est le rapport oxfam on s'en sert
beaucoup en ce moment un lot angie oxfam
qui est une ong 5 mondial qui lutte
contre la précarité contre la pauvreté
les inégalités et ils disent tout
simplement il ya un chiffre qui est
fabuleux c'est les ultra riches en
france ces 43 milliardaire ils sont
accaparés ils ont augmenté leur fortune
de 236 milliards d'euros en 19 mois
c'est à dire les dix-neuf fois de la
crise sanitaire et nous on dit ben voilà
on n'est pas très fort en mathématiques
mais on se dit qu'il ya eu un truc
arithmétique la 236 milliards et bien
cela on les reprend et on les
redistribue différemment et en fait le
problème de la redistribution des
richesses parce que c'est ça qui est
posée quoi c'est c'est peu quand on sait
que ça viendra pas d'en haut
les mythes du ruissellement vous allez
voir plus on est riche plus on fera
profiter la population c'est des
conneries donc du coup si on veut
vraiment que la population elle profite
des richesses collectives des richesses
qui ces dernières sont produites par le
travail de millions et de dizaines de
millions d'individus pour en profiter ça
veut dire que c'est à nous d'aller le
chercher et aller le chercher bah c'est
sa pause de près d'un combat politique
ça pose deux problèmes une mobilisation
générale de la population est ce un
problème d'horaire remise en cause de la
propriété en fait il faut enlever le
pouvoir aux riches on passe à la
prochaine question pareille toujours je
vous laisse
appuyez ça va s'arrêter sur un
téléphone c'est un téléphone en
l'occurrence ce téléphone concrètement
c'est un écran de téléphone qui va
apparaître et derrière du coup ça et
bien les applications à l'intérieur
je vous repose du coup qu'on voit déjà
ce téléphone en question vous voyez
différentes applications je sais pas
chez nous est arrivé à allier enfin y'a
du netflix airbnb youtuber des livres ou
et c'est donc là se pose la question
quand on est anticapitaliste qu'est-ce
qu'on fait typiquement ses demandes et
président de toutes ces sociétés qui
sont existantes en france si on centre
un peu la question première question
quand même sur hubert et des livres où
ces applis de livraison henry burris
précisément et délai vous qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec philippe poutou
président qu'est ce qu'on fait de ces de
ses applications et services alors pas
avec pour philippe poutou président mais
avec un pouvoir différents et de société
un peu l'horizon différemment mais moi
je pense qu'apple sur ce qu'ils vont
disparaître parce que la plupart de ces
de ces sachets celui-ci le sait les
résultats des attaques contre le droit
des salariés le code du travail la
libéralisation la précarisation de
l'emploi et tout ça ça n'est là dessus
quoi ce sont des il est évident que si
on discute de protection sociale pour
l'ensemble de la population si on
discute de statut non précaires et avec
des salaires auront géré j'ai reçu c'est
évident que ça ça ne peut plus exister
c'est vrai que donc du coup ça
disparaîtra donc ça disparaîtra pas
d'autorité mais en fait le fond du
problème c'est d'arriver à faire une
société qui respecte tout le monde est
donc en rediscute des recrutements de la
formation des salaires décents nous on
pense qu'il faut un smic à 1 800 euros
minimum et un revenu même pour toute la
population qui permettent de vivre
notamment pour la jeunesse à revenu
d'autonomie donc tout cas partie ment ou
discutent de ces bases là qui sont pour
nous les fondements d'une société
solidaire d'une société qui permettent à
toulouse mais ça ça gicle forcément en
conséquence et dans quelle mesure est ce
qu'on en est capable et qu'est ce qu'on
peut mettre concrètement en place je
m'en aille burris un des livres ou cd
services qui ont beaucoup rocourt a
effectivement des contrats qui ne sont
pas forcément des contrats de salariés
justement c'est une question que vous
posez là c'est pas concrètement si se
dire demain dans ce modèle de société
que vous imaginez combien des livres ou
un aubry tout un équivalent c'est pareil
c'est une obligation d'avoir un statut
de salarié en tant que libraire mais
même ça ce que des livres ou ibérique
est ce qu'on a besoin vraiment enfin
c'est c'est après le problème nous
disent qu'on discute c'est qu'en fait on
n'a pas un plan de la société de demain
qui est complètement établie c'est que
nous on discute que déjà il ya des
droits pour toutes et tous et l'égalité
des droits la bataille et puis donc la
mise en place d'une société qui avait
acquis ce temps se pose le problème de
comment on répond aux besoins de la
population après dans l'exactitude
comment ça se passe on sait pas parce
que l'idée c'est quand même
l'autogestion c'est par en bas c'est
comment dans les quartiers dans les
villes dans les régions même à un niveau
national ou international sait comment
la population s'organise fait de la
politique et puis en place des choses et
à partir de là quelles seront les
conséquences concrètes on n'en sait rien
et puis même comment petit à petit
le secteur privé diminuerez et ce serait
le secteur public qui serait dominant on
n'en sait pas mais nous on essaie de
dire que c'est possible de faire
autrement il faut faire autrement sinon
s'en sort pas on va avancer avec une
autre une autre question
même chose à les stopper tout ça et ça
s'arrête sur un d alors on va pas faire
un jeu de plateau on a pas de table sont
pour faire un jeu de plateau mais
concrètement das était logé à chaque
fois lors de ces formats d'interviews on
va reprendre le principe général d'un
jeu qui est connu souvent notamment des
jeunes en l'occurrence ici on va faire
un jeu que vous connaissez peut-être qui
s'appelle le tu préfères alors le vous
préférez dans le cadre et si dans une
interview et l'idée ça consiste à faire
un choix entre deux propositions qui
sont volontairement parfois un peu
particulière parfois d'ailleurs est une
plus sérieuse mais qui peuvent amener du
coup une réflexion qui est importante et
on va commencer du coup avec la première
c'est une question allant l'occurrence
qui est assez sérieuse quand même très
sérieuse
en supposant qu'ils aient un second tour
entre emmanuel macron face à le pen ou
vers un autre un autre candidat ou alors
le fait de ne pas aller voter
qu'est ce que vous faites prenons cette
situation un second tour face à le pen
ou le fait de ne pas aller voter
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce qu'on fait
c'est ce qui s'est passé en 2010 est un
bep ne pas aller voter ne pas aller
voter en 17 et la même chose en 2022 si
malheureusement là des second tour de ce
style raid la situation avec disant que
peut-être que peut-être qu'à l'époque
pour le vote on n'a pas hésité mais
peut-être qu'à l'époque et c'est vrai
qu'à l'époque macron il avait une image
un peu il avait pas l'image violente et
arrogante qu'il a aujourd'hui dans la
campagne qui l'avait mené et on savait
que le pen c'était la réac et raciste
fasciste aussi on savait ça et macro et
mais on savait qu macron c'était un
banquier un ultralibéral n'y avait
aucune illusion dans ce qu'ils pouvaient
faire on voit bien qu'un seul un tour
alors on va pas faire de politique d'
hypothèses ou quoi mais dans le cas où
cette situation se présenteraient vous
ces abstentions vous n'irez pas voter
vraiment plus que macron c'est darmanin
ces blancs caire des gens ultra réac
dont on sait en plus quand même que ils
ont des proximités politique avec des
idées mais celle de la peine et l'extra
match on le voit aujourd'hui comment les
un les assauts garda c'est sûr que pour
un second tour comme ça si ces macro ou
le pen est évidemment qu'on va pas voter
mais c'est pas juste ne pas aller voter
c'est poser le problème que il ya une
bataille sociale à mener mais même dès
aujourd'hui en fait en réalité même
pendant la campagne électorale
besoin de se lancer dans une lutte
unitaire anti fasciste et l'anti
fascisme c'est à la fois contre le pen
contre zemmour y compris contre la
droite de pécresse parce qu'on voit que
finalement les frontières il n'ya pas il
ya plus de frontières quoi et facebook
qui j'ai fait pécresse dans la droite on
imagine assez facilement que les gens
bien on le voit comment ça se croisent
comment les gens choisissent des écuries
différentes zemmour c'est le discours
facile ça c'est sûr le pen c'est une
forme de fascisme a rajouté un peu
arrondie tout est un peu match est moins
clair aujourd'hui mais la droite oui une
partie et puis même du côté du
gouvernement du côté de macron du côté
darmana c'est qu'on nous parce qu'un
danger fasciste et y compris dur
aujourd'hui dans l'appareil d'état qui y
compris dans les syndicats policiers
d'extrême droite et donc du coup c'est
pas juste ne pas aller voter c est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on a la force commencé
pour se défendre relever la tête et
mener une bataille dans la rue aussi
contre ces idées là donc c'est pas ça se
pose pas juste comme ça on vote pas puis
on voit la suite il ya aussi un combat
politique à mener la 2e delà de ce vote
il va passer la toute dernière question
on va arrêter du coup le
maire question c'est sûr du coup le
drapeau français celui-ci vous l'aurez
vous l'aurez reconnu avec une forme un
peu particulière mais tout de même très
concrètement ça c'est une question qui
sera posée à tous les candidats en fait
on va reprendre une formule de françois
hollande que vous connaissez forcément
celle qu'il avait prononcé en 2012 face
à nicolas sarkozy le fameux mois
président 1 lille est temps que vous
puissiez complété comme vous le faire
les autres candidats une série de
phrases avec ce qui vous semble le plus
pertinent selon votre vision de la
société je vous laisse du coup ça vous
va lire
chaque phrase est complétée au face à ce
qu'il a dit ça non non ça c'est une
version on a ajusté la version donc
jamais vous voulez lire cette phrase là
et au fur et à mesure remplir avec ce
qui vous semble le plus pertinent sur
votre vision de la société en enchaînant
les différentes les différentes phases
ben déjà on dira pas moi président c'est
pas beau c'est bon on peut pas le dire
en fait un blocage psychologique ça
parle et je vais nouveau pouvoir ou un
vrai gouvernement ou un vrai pouvoir
pour la population et les jeunes alors
sauront je sais pas comment dire mais
parce que nous on
on voit bien là l'accès à l'éducation
dans les facs on voit bien le parcours
sup enfin les dégâts que ça fait de
nombreux bacheliers nombreuses
bachelière clients qu'ils peuvent pas
avoir accès aux études supérieures donc
il vous fait c'est l'axé et puis et puis
la question du revenu parce que tout est
lié pouvoir étudier dans les meilleures
conditions donc ça pose un problème d'un
d'un revenus autonomes faits qui
permettent autonomie de la jeunesse
comme moi président nous président mon
ennemi ou notre ennemi sera ben ça sera
les fachos les ultra riches
et puis tout tout tout ce qui peut être
nationalistes souverainistes enfin nous
on veut en vendre sans frontières donc
d'ailleurs le drapeau blanc rouge c'est
pas un truc qu'on porte parce qu on est
quand même particulièrement hostile à
tout ce qui peut mettre des frontières
entre les peuples voilà nous président
notre première mesure sera nous le
nouveau pouvoir où nous notre première
mesure ça sera assez difficile de dire
la première mesure comme et ya forcément
une réponse sociale c'est les services
publics de santé quoi sa fille de santé
l'énergie et des transports enfin voilà
ça va être la priorité m remettre en
place des services qui répondent enfin
qui permettent l'accès à la population à
ces choses qui sont parlé et ça explique
de l'alimentation aussi parce que ça
fait partie des choses à la première
visite officielle sera
alors notre première visite officielle
mais il y avait plein de choses à faire
soit c'est une visite qui permet de
poser le problème des migrants et la
question de la liberté d'installation et
de circulation d'ouverture des
frontières ça peut être avec tous celles
et ceux qui agissent dans la mairie de
tergnier notamment sos méditerranée ça
serait ce genre de l'erika code de m et
puis de voir comment peu épuisé après ce
serait une visite soit avec des
militants algériens ou d où des
militants et militantes chilienne de
faire le lien avec des révoltes
populaires et de montrer comme ça tout
ça je l'aï même le nouveau pouvoir et il
en appelle aussi à une solidarité
internationale des populations des
peuples - président la france sera pour
terminer en deux mots elle sera alors en
tire anti colonialiste anti impérialiste
elle donnera
l'autonomie à la can à qui elle donnera
à l'indépendance à toutes celles et ceux
qui le veulent y compris la corse où le
pays basque fait voilà c'est aussi cette
idée là quoi c'est cette idée d'un pays
ouvert aux autres et qui mettra en
application les principes
internationaliste que vous qu'on a eu
l'occasion d'évoquer d'évoquer
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté encore une fois mr interview
avec ce format un peu particulier mais
d'avoir pris le temps de les changer sur
le fond ce qui nous semble important
alors le fait avec vous on va le faire
avec tous les candidats dans l'est dans
les prochains jours pour ceux qui
tombent peut-être sur cette vidéo
notamment sur youtube que j'aime et vous
voulez plus d'informations que ce soit
sur tous les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle est bien sur cette même
chaîne youtube vous allez retrouver dans
les prochains jours des interviews de
tous les candidats ainsi que des
décryptages de tous les candidats pour
mieux comprendre concrètement qui
propose quoi évidemment n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner je ne sais pas encore le
cas pour ne pas louper les vidéos
suivantes à nous suivre aussi sur les
autres réseaux connaissances vous et on
se dit du coup a très vite